we think of time as something that we're
like in a relationship with and so it
naturally becomes something that we've
got to try to sort of use well or we
could be guilty of wasting or we want to
sort of feel confident that the near
future is going to unfold in a certain
way and actually time isn't really like
this we're treating it as something that
ultimately it it isn't because
you don't really have time you just get
given each moment as it comes and you
don't know how more much more of it
you'll have and you can't really put it
aside all those things that sort of the
language and the metaphor of
like physical possessions ownership and
management
yeah doesn't quite work so you're
constantly approaching your time
with a sort of set of concepts that
aren't quite properly suited to what it
really is and i think that's because
it's kind of uncomfortable and
ultimately if you go deep enough
probably quite terrifying to face up to
the real truth of the situation which is
that all the time is just completely
vulnerable to anything that might happen
next